so let's move on Amy chose Xbox a Singh
Hillary ten years to presidential
commands in campaigns in one intact
ceiling among the coats who emerged they
never were gonna let me be president why
does everyone hate me these are the type
of things that bring the DNC down are
they tell me what's going on in DNC
circles this help or hurt your case well
I mean look those quotes themselves when
they're standalone is in the way that
they're being presented of course it
doesn't sound good but anybody who's
gonna run for president win by two point
nine million popular votes lose the
electoral college by roughly sixty
thousand votes if they had swung that's
a tough way to lose that hurts it
doesn't feel good and that's what she
was expressing that night I can't blame
her for not feeling good about that and
you went either if you ran for president
lost like that that's a tough way to
lose but you're right looking forward to
2020 of the 2018 midterms we're looking
for some fresh ideas fresh blood and
there are a lot of people within the
Democratic Party who are stepping up
right now a couple of things I want to
download all of her excuses I ran out of
toner so I had to quick start the show
it's been incredible I give so much
spirit to people like Al Gore well had
his heart broken never complained again
just would have some fun with it on talk
shows and then you have Richard Nixon
who knew there was some for something uh
uneasy about what happened in Illinois
he said it was better for the country to
move on I wish Hillary Clinton would
read those biographies thanks a lot even
appreciate it